Das hier ist der Tower-Simulator der Flugsicherung des österreichischen Bundesheeres.
Ein Kleinsimulator wo Fluglotsen, die im Tower-Business tätig sind auf den 4 österreichischen Militärflugplätzen,
Neustadt, Aigen, Langenlebarn und Zeltweg, hier die möglichkeit haben Szenarien zu trainieren
die hoffentlich in der Realität nicht vorkommen wie zb. Notverfahren.
Der Lotse ist hier in der Lage Sachen zu üben, zu trainieren, Notverfahren,
die er analog per Checkliste abarbeiten muss.
Weiters gilt dieser Tower-Simulator auch zum Training der Militärfluglotsen.
Wenn neue Plätze im Ausland errichtet werden, Beispielsweise,
kann man sich hier auf diesen möglichen Einsatz vorbereiten.
Wir bewegen uns in einem Zeitraum von 3-4 Wochen bis ein Flugplatz
von unserem technischen Support verfügbar ist.
Somit können wir gezielt Fluglotsen auf einen auswertigen Platz, egal wo, weltweit vorbereiten
und er kann bereits hier im Simulator für
diesen Platz an diesem Platz trainieren.